so you asked a simple question
invisibility just decades away we will
have something resembling Harry Potter's
invisibility cloak something equally
astonishing is shape-shifting when you
see science fiction movies like
Terminator 2 and you see the evil robot
turn into jelly and then mousse this way
through obstacles you say to yourself no
way no way can that happen believe it or
not we scientists are making huge
inroads into that area
it's called programmable matter matter
itself that could rearrange itself
change color change shape change
conductivity by pushing a button and
here's how it works why is it that
certain substances can turn liquid and
ooze its way across the room like in the
movie Terminator 2 it's because of atoms
atoms can slide over atoms rearrange
themselves but what happens if atoms are
replaced by chips chips that are so
small they're smaller than the head of a
pin and you can change their electric
charge by changing the electric charge
they bind and reform in different ways
and they're intelligent because each dot
is a computer chip
perhaps as powerful as a PC these are
called Katims and who's pushing this
technology the Intel Corporation the
makers of the famous Pentium chip that
drives your laptop the same company is
now investigating the next several steps
in the future the ability to have
programmable matter now think about it
it means that if I have a clump of clay
made out of thousands of millions of
little dots I push a button then the
charges rearrange themselves to form a
statue a car whatever you want this
means that I can push another button and
this clay turns into a house or I push
another button and a whole city a whole
city Rises out of the desert sounds like
science fiction but the basic steps are
being done today and in fact with the
television crew I went to Carnegie
Mellon University in Pittsburgh and
photographed it of course these Katims
are quite large they're about the size
of a head of a pin
but it's only a matter of time before
these Katims become so microscopic and
so powerful that they'll be able to
rearrange just like what you see in
Terminator 2 just I could see what you
see in the Transformers just like what
you see in x-men comics